Oh
güzel ne kadar
iyi bugün burada
Aslında ortaokul ortaokul
öğretmeni o
bu
hayal edilmiş
hayalet
önce bir dolar gittim
etmek istiyorum
şuan olmayı
İyi o zaman da yağ etmiş Çünkü bir hayal
destanlar büyük bir hayal dünyası
karşıda çıkmışsın sonra hayat gittim
[Müzik]
ve Maşa önce Nestle sor pixi 4 makine
bölümünde oldu mu
bu ay Kafam gibi ya da
başka iş artışı günlük sayı Vardı be
zarar Bir dahaki
onların etrafında
sürekli devam ve
O da
bu içmeyle takipçi var
bir hayatımdaki
arkeoloji macerada işte neden yaz
okuduğum
büyük bir şey yok ki
ve o gecede futbol Kitap okudum
Kapıdan çıkarken de
[Müzik]
en iyi Gez başlayacağım iş koyduk
çalışmış 88 suya
geldim ben
da kapanınca bir sürü hayaller olmuş
vallahi
yani
Ortaokulda sonrasında
şimdi pek çok şeyi hayal etme
88 korkmadan çok zor değil c&a
bu
gerçekleştiği ya da gerçekleri hayale
dönüştü yer ne demek
insanlarının Öykü geçtiği yer ve burada
biz aradın tarihçesine baktığımızda
[Müzik]
öğrendiğin de O
insanları
üstümüzde şimdi zaman
onun
şiirsel
politik hava sıkıldığınız zaman
gerçekten
yani ayağı o sizi götürüyor başka başka
hayalleri bir götürüyor Arkadaşlar bunun
bir tarafında
88 30 oluyor
maceramız başladı
burada da
o kadar da bazı hayallerimiz var
Birincisi
Roya gerçekten çok önemli israf o çok
önemli işte
buranın
bu hayali O zaman pek çok
zorladı o
1098 gibi sonra dünya kültür mirası
silah üniversite yine
çok önemli güçlü
[Müzik]
olur mu olmaz mı özellikleri
o 90'lı yılların sonundan itibaren yine
geçirirsiniz
çektiği Hayal vardı o
bu daha sonra anlattığım tuşuna yağı
bulma suyu keşfetme
tanrının bir hayali uzun olmadığını
hayat ve kendi hayali hayal ürünü olduğu
iddia edilen bir
destanın gerçekliği saat
Bu
biraz
[Müzik]
ve o
bu
işte 30'lu yıllarda kendisinden sonra
başka nokta hayalet işimizi ilk kez
soyada
bir orjinal dünyada olacağız şimdi kızı
orada ilk kez görülen sonra 60 kızın
yeniden
canlanması orada ilk kez suya
Savaşı'nın gerçek doğru 61 lerde
ilişkilendirildiği buluşlar 30'lu
yıllarda gerçekleşmiş Bu konuşmanın ismi
için
dövme ayağa Biz bunu müziği içinde
açılan şiiri bir şekilde giden bir
çıksa altında görebilir miyiz
göremezsiniz bu hayali koltuk ve bu
hayal yaklaşık yirmi yıl bu hayali
peşinden koştuk ve bu hayalimizde
1980-2018 yılında gerçek olduğu
Boğazı
Bulutlarda kısmen geri döndü bu süreçte
de
[Müzik]
Evet şimdi anlıyorsun
yani nasıl
yavaş daha sonra beş bekliyorsunuz
olmayan bir olay
oluyor Bunlar
gerçek
[Müzik]
Korkma
çok yakın o
Evet şunu öğrenci hayatlarına şunu da
gitti istediğiniz
bu yeter benzettin istediğin şeyi
pişman hoşunuza yapmış
konuşursa Hayaller kur söylüyorsunuz ve
ısrarcı sabırlı olduysa
hayallerimizin gerçek olduğunu görürüz
Bugün ben buraya İzmir'den geldim ve
İzmir'de
Bu yolu genişliği ve
Hayaller o hayallerin gerçekleşir Sizin
attığınız
adımlarla
Ben şimdi
4-5 dakika
hoşmuş ve Bence o
[Müzik]
o
dünkü aynı işi ciddi anlamda başladık
aynı kimi dönüşüyor Hayallerinin
peşinden koştuğu için 20 dönüştüğü
birler
Müzesi'nde o dönemdeki kızlardan daha
sonra
93-94
[Müzik]
bu Bu
garibi de yaşayan
insanların fotoğrafları Aynı zamanda da
[Müzik]
1932'de 38 aslında burada şöyle bir
ilişki hafta var yani
ve 32
[Müzik]
Az önce
başlayan kuştan
hayallerini diğer kızlarla devam ediyor
büyük
alanlarını arkadaş Bir de vefat etmek
sağlamlaştırmak yazılı
gerçekten o
[Müzik]
da
akülü
oluyor
[Müzik]
Bir Köy 32a
bu
[Müzik]
kurduğu hayallerin içine düştü yani
hoş değil
[Müzik]
bir yanlışlık ister misin de
konuşuyorlar çocuklar
bir kaç lira
çalışmış o
[Müzik]
Bu
bir kısmı hala onların yazın Eğer
geldiğimizde sonra renginize şimdiki bir
olarak çalışırken bilirsiniz Ben bu mm
olduğuydu bir odanın şimdi çalışıyoruz
onların
Evet bu da
da
Ankara'daki Türk Tarih Kongresi hangi
benim hayalimizi hayatımız yanında büyük
bir günlük geçtiği kızlar Bunlar
sadece
Beraber çalışıyorduk şu an 125
bu Ama bu süreç içinde de sürekli yeni 7
şeylerin burçları bitkileri ve
Hayallerini peşinde koşturan
[Müzik]
11.co bunun
içinde
[Müzik]
Anadolu b&o
o
90'lı yılların ortası sabah beş buçuk
işlerin
yoklaması bu Osmanlı
sohbet ettiği ve
işçiliğinde
azalma
sabah o
abone ol
Yok
[Müzik]
ya ben özetle şunu söylemiştim ya bizim
Anadolu toprakları Anadolu kültürü dünya
kültür mirası listesinde
bir çıkartmış insanlık tarihinin pek çok
farklı aşamalarının son anlarının
yaşandığı yer
yanlışlık
yaşandı Ama mı
Allah
herkesin ya da ki Çünkü çocukların
hayalini süsleyen diğer bu hayali
beşinden koşan işlerde de burada
çalışmaya devam ediyoruz Herkese çok
teşekkür et